Throughout the conflict in Ukraine,
significant territorial shifts have
occurred. Russia, at one point, advanced close to
major urban centers such as Kyiv and Kherson,
occupying farmlands and strategic rural areas.
While their military presence has
since diminished, they have left a
lasting and destructive legacy
on Ukrainian soil: landmines.
A cruel and long-lasting weapon designed to act as
a deterrent for military personnel moving in
to recapture land taken from them. However,
once the positions are abandoned the
mines stay. Concealed underground,
they continue to pose significant threats for
years or decades after the conflict's conclusion,
hindering agricultural activities, restricting
civilian mobility, and causing lasting trauma.
Starting in 2014 with the
Russian occupation of Crimea,
the southern part of Ukraine became
contaminated with minefields. [1][REF]
7 years of tedious work went into demining
an area of 23,000 square kilometers.
In 18 months, all that work went to waste,
as this area plus another 150,000 square
kilometers, is now contaminated with mines
once again. This accounts for 30% of
Ukraine’s total land area, roughly the
size of Florida. Making Ukraine the country
with the largest area contaminated by mines.
The regions affected are concentrated in the east,
where most of the conflict is happening but also
include areas near the country's capital, Kiev,
where the Russian army got worryingly close to
2022. These mines are already starting to take
a toll on the Ukrainian people as 298 civilians
have been killed, 22 of them being children,
with over 600 injured. [2]REF] Unfortunately,
these numbers are only going to grow. It
is estimated that it will take Ukraine
750 years to clear its land using current
demining and detection techniques.[3][REF]
So what exactly are landmines, and
what tools do we have to detect and
destroy them? Let's delve deeper into
the painful task facing Ukraine.
There are two types of landmines, larger ones that
are designed to disable or destroy large vehicles,
like tanks and smaller ones
designed to maim individuals,
and Ukraine is unfortunately littered with both.
The Russian PFM-1 [4][REF] is a small plastic case
mine filled with 37 grams of liquid explosives.
Nicknamed the butterfly mine, their small
wings allow them to be dropped from the air,
whether by mortar, helicopter or airplane.
The unsymmetrical wings allow them to glide
and spin to the ground like a helicopter
seed. Landing softly on the ground,
waiting for an unsuspecting victim.
When stood on, the thin plastic deforms
which increases the pressure on the liquid
inside the casing, causing it to explode.
Because they are camouflaged
and contain little metal,
detection of these sinister weapons is
extremely challenging. Their lightweight
nature also allows them to be carried
by water, potentially reaching civilian
areas where children can mistake them for
toys, making them particularly inhumane.
The Russian PMN-2 Landmine
is a general-purpose mine
that also uses a plastic casing
to minimize metal components.
It is buried between 5 to 10
centimeters below the surface,
and contains around 100g of TNT
[5][REF][REF-old]. It detonates
with a force of around 15 kilograms, low
enough to be triggered by stepping on it.
But, mines aren’t only activated by pressure.
To create impediments along roads
or entrances to building the OZM-72
Landmine uses a trip wire as a trigger
to explode 660 grams of TNT. [6][REF]
Anti-tank mines, unlike those targeting
individuals, require more TNT to penetrate
heavily armored tanks and are designed to detonate
under larger pressures. The M1 Abrams tanks
recently sent to Ukraine will face TM-62 land
mines, which detonate only when objects weighing
over 150 kilograms pass over them, delivering a
powerful 7.5 kilograms TNT explosion. [7] [REF]
Since 2021, the Russian army
has employed the PTKM-1R,
a novel mine designed to target the upper
and less armored sections of the tanks.
The mine is not triggered
by passing over it, instead
it is equipped with two seismic sensors
for detecting tank movements and four
microphones to capture loud sounds. [8][REF]
Once a tank is detected,it tilts
60 degrees toward the target and
launches a munition 30 meters above the tank.
In a parabolic trajectory, infrared and radar
sensors activate the second explosive phase,
deploying a shaped charge to penetrate
the tank from above. [9] [REF]
Tools to help detect and destroy these
mines have mostly come from the US.
Anti-mine equipment is listed as part of the
latest 600 million dollar aid package to Ukraine
in September 2023. [10][REF].
What do these tools look like?
The tools chosen to demine an area depend
on the current phase of the conflict and
the lands intended use after the mine
has been removed. Military demining,
intended to establish secure pathways
for highly trained soldiers and heavily
reinforced equipment, is carried out
very differently from demining efforts
in civilian areas used for farming
or where children will play freely.
So how does the military deal with
all these mines? With brute force.
Mine clearance line charges can create a
secure path in minutes. [11][REF].
These are long lines containing C4
explosive pellets, attached to a central
nylon rope along with detonation wires.
The line is attached to a solid propellant
rocket placed on an angled guide. When fired
it pulls the 100 meter line taut along the
desired path. Then a line is detonated.
The explosion creates enough pressure
to detonate any mines below the surface,
4m at each side of the line. [11]
[REF]. If a longer path is needed the
machine will roll along the recently
created path and repeat the process.
This method prioritizes speed, for
when enemies are nearby or troops
need to move quickly to the front lines,
but this method comes at a high costs,
each line costs $83,000 thousands. [12][REF]
But what if speed is not as important?
Like when the enemy has retreated and
you need to secure key positions.
In some cases fields have been set
on fire in Ukraine to clear them
of the small plastic PFM-1 mines.
Armored tanks, resistant to smaller
mine explosions outfitted with tools
to either detonate or push
aside mines can also be used.
One method to do this uses chain linked
flails. As the vehicle moves forward these
flails strike and detonate the mines. [13][REF].
This often breaks the flail, causing chain links
to fly off into the distance, but additional
links can easily be attached to repair them.
Detonation may not always be
necessary to clear a path. A
plow attachment on the M1 Abrams tank
can dig into the soil beneath the mines
and push mines out of the way without
triggering them from above. [14] [REF]
In recent years, smaller remote controlled flailed
vehicles have started to operate. [13][REF]
Ukrainian farmers desperate to start cultivating
again have even retrofitted some of their farming
equipment to be remote-controlled and have started
to unofficially demine their lands. [15] [REF]
Using armored vehicles like these for mine
clearing does have some limitations. They are
unsuitable for rough terrain and dense vegetation,
where maneuverability is compromised. In open
areas, such as those in Ukraine, they become
conspicuous targets that the enemy can anticipate.
Ukrainian soldiers have reported that the
Leopard tank is particularly vulnerable
when engaged in minefield clearance. It is
frequently targeted by the Russian Army since
disabling the tank will significantly
impede the Ukrainian forces' progress.
These methods can remove 80%
to 90% of mines. [16] [REF]
Mines that do not detonate either become further
buried or remain alongside the cleared path.
Within military standards, this level of
effectiveness is considered acceptable, as
soldiers are trained to spot mines on the ground
and can more easily navigate and avoid them.
The last 10 to 20% of mines are the
ones that stay in the ground. Or if
a military operation does not pass through a
contaminated area the mines stay there until
a civilian gets injured. Removing these
mines is known as Humanitarian demining.
Ukraine is not the first country
to be scattered with mines in
civilian areas. Cambodia was infested with
landmines during the Khmer Rouge regime.
Three decades later, only half of the land has
been cleared and they already have claimed the
lives of 64,000 people [17] [REF]. Even highly
trafficked tourist regions like Siem Riep have
ominous mine warning signs, a constant reminder
not to venture off the beaten path surrounding
Cambodia's ancient temples, and the devastation
these mines have had on the civilian population
is a confronting reminder to tourists of the
very recent genocide the country endured.
In Afghanistan, landmines were indiscriminately
laid during the Soviet occupation between 1979 and
1992, and continue to be laid down by the Taliban
today. [18] [REF] This has injured or killed
almost 57, 000 people in the country. In 2021,
79% of the casualties were children. [19] [REF]
A small town in Mozambique was
evacuated due to rumors of mines
in the surrounding area. Three months
later, only 4 were found [20] [REF].
The power of landmines comes
not only from their instant
destructive capabilities but also due
to their ability to scare people away.
These are inhumane weapons
that disproportionately kill
and maim innocent civilians long
after the conflict is resolved.
In early 2022, the Kakhovka
dam near Kherson, Ukraine,
was destroyed. The estimated 500 mines in
the area that were not properly removed
or destroyed by the military have now
potentially been dispersed by the floods.
They may become buried deeper under debris or
end up in entirely new locations. [21] [REF]
Uncleared mines are a major
humanitarian challenge,
especially as the UN standard requires a
100% clearance rate within designated zones.
Ofcourse, to prevent harm from these mines,
the first step is to cease their use entirely.
The Ottawa Treaty, also known as the
Mine Ban Treaty, prohibits the use,
production, stockpiling, and transfer of smaller
anti-personnel mines, but it
excludes those targeting tanks.
The Ottawa Treaty has been widely
embraced by the international community,
with over 160 signatory countries.
Unsurprisingly, it excludes Russia,
the US, China, India, and Pakistan,
the world's largest military forces.
The U.S. reserved the right to use
so-called "non persistent landmines,"
which self-destruct or self-deactivate after 30
days to reduce the risk to civilians. [22] [REF]
The rationale behind this policy was to support
the defense of South Korea, where landmines
played a significant role as a deterrent against
potential aggression from North Korea. [23] [REF]
Russia told the UN in 2020, that it “supports the
world without mines” but they still see them as an
essential tool to ensure border security. [REF].
When not on the front line, the method
for locating these mines primarily
involves the use of metal detectors.
Metal detectors are a simple tool.
They are made out of a coil of
wire with a pulsing current,
which causes a changing magnetic field to
propagate through the ground. Any metal
in the soil interacts with this field,
and causes an audible beep for the user.
The user's sole source of information
is the strength of the beep,
which communicates the size and proximity
of the object. Consequently, operators
must undergo rigorous training
to interpret the auditory cues.
Upon hearing a beep, deminers
move to investigate the alarm.
The most common way to do this is
using a small stick. At an angle,
to avoid the top of the mines, they poke
the area in search of something solid.
The probe can be anything from
a screwdriver to more sensitive
force-measuring probing sticks that help
assess the hardness of buried metal,
allowing for the differentiation of shrapnel
from potential landmines. [24] [REF]
This is a slow and tedious process that just
adds stress to the already pressured deminers.
Here lies the problem with using these
simple tools, they detect any sort of
metal in the ground, it can either be a
mine or some shrapnel. In war-torn areas,
where shrapnel is common, soldiers
looking for mines get false alarms
between 100 to 1000 times for every
mine they discover. [25] [REF]
To develop a more advanced demining system, the
U.S. Army initiated a substantial investment in
1992, allocating a total of 73 million dollars
over a fifteen-year period [24] [REF]. The
objective was to establish the gold
standard in demining technology,
resulting in the Handheld Standoff
Mine Detection System in 2006.
The system uses two sensors. Combining a metal
detector with a ground penetrating radar.
The radar gives the operator a better idea of the
size, geometry and depth of the detected object.
Allowing them to filter out false positives
that metal detectors frequently provide.
Since its introduction, it's been used
in Cambodia, Thailand, Afghanistan,
and Croatia to find over 56,000 mines and
reject 33 million false signals. [26] [REF]
Alternatively we can detect mines through their
smell. Dogs have been successfully trained to
identify mines. Including the famous jack russell
terrier of the Ukraine war who has helped detect
hundreds of explosives. Small dogs are ideal for
the job as they are too light to trigger mines.
Rats are useful for the same reason.
Off-the-shelf drones can detect
signs of mines that have been buried,
and in situations where landmines are placed
directly on the ground or dispersed from the
air like the PFM-1, drones can simply go
up and spot them from above. [27][REF]
However, efforts are being made to develop
machine vision algorithms with both visible
and infrared spectrums to detect these
landmines automatically, and they could
potentially be fitted with projectiles to
target the mine from the air. [28] [REF]
Landmines will continue to plague
Ukraine for the coming decades even
if the war ends now. Hopefully these
new techniques and technologies can
accelerate the clearance of
this new colossal minefield,
but Ukraine also needs additional resources
to clear the way for their advancing soldiers.
So, to play our part we will be donating 2000
dollars to The Halo Trust an NGO dedicated to
clearing minefields around the world, including
Ukraine, while campaigning for the banning of
mines altogether. That money will be coming
directly out of our sponsor fee for Nebula,
and for every one of you that signs up to Nebula
we will donate another dollar to the cause.
It costs just 2.50 to sign
up to Nebula for a month,
so that’s 40% of your monthly fee going
directly to charity, and you will get
access to all the amazing content on Nebula too.
Including the next episode of Real Engineering,
which won't be on YouTube for another two
weeks. It details the incredible engineering
of the F-16. Diving into energy-maneuverability
diagrams and the engineering that will make the
F-16 a formidable tool for the Ukrainian air
force, four decades after its first flight,
with an interview from an experienced test
pilot and former F-16 pilot David Kern.
You can get access to that right now with the
huge discounted price of just 2.50 a month,
using the link in the description. But
early access to our videos is just one
benefit. You will also get access
to our original world war 2 series,
the Logistics of D-Day and the Battle
of Britain. As well as Real Life Lore’s
modern conflict series that deep dives
into conflicts like the War in Ukraine.
Along with originals from some of your
other favourite creators, Like Mustard,
Practical Engineering, Neo
and Wendover Productions.
Nebula is simply the best place for
our videos. No ads, ad free videos,
exclusive high budget originals and
all for the price of 2.50 a month.